j'accueille maintenant muriel robin
oui
et oui muriel triomphera sinon comment
en même temps a eu lieu en province
comme ça en battant à savoir les saisir
quand même très mais vous savez pourquoi
non parce que bon il ya la pièce 2
minimath i o vous êtes auteur avec
pierre palmade
ils se sont aimés qu'il joue tous les
soirs avec michèle laroque au théâtre de
la porte saint martin est un énorme
succès c'est ce qui fait en ce moment
palmade
pierre
et doit faire flasher j'te l'heure
c'est un sujet dont l'écriture scénique
la lectrice stark a pris la parole c'est
pas comme des maux bleus
donc j'ai dit mimi mathy la pièce donc
ils se sont aimés palmade laroque
vous êtes toujours très impliqué dans
les restos du coeur et les trois
concerts à à marseille
vous êtes marraine de l'association des
enfants afghans
nous recevrons tout à l'heure ni la mob
ares qui nous parlera de de son action
et de la vôtre par la même occasion
voilà quoi donc c'est ça mérite un
triomphe romain c'est ça c'est mieux que
je peux faire autre chose on va en
parler alors on a déjà parlé de votre
famille la dernière fois vous êtes venu
il ya deux ans à bienne a besoin de
chaussures les portes que oui là je sais
déjà ils vont donc aujourd'hui on va
parler un peu du nôtre famille c'est
comment on fait
alors cet autre famille
muriel robin haase et celles qui vous
entourent dans la griffe la pièce que
vous interprétez à partir du 29 janvier
au théâtre fontaine avec berlin vers
l'est c'est une pièce qui est écrite par
claude d'anna et laure bonnet et mise en
scène par annick blancheteau voilà